Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Le temps que je prononce
ces quelques phrases,
il y aurait eu 1,5 million
d’orgasmes dans le monde,
selon le site globalorgasm.org,
dimanche après-midi plutôt banal.
Mais j’ai une mauvaise
nouvelle à vous annoncer :
ces chiffres ne nous concernent pas.
Quoique.
Je ne sais pas vous, mais moi aussi,
j’ai envie de prendre mon pied.
Petite différence : on va rester habillés
et assis sur une chaise, s’il vous plaît.
Aujourd’hui, je vais vous parler
de plaisir sexuel
et plus particulièrement
de sa place dans nos quotidiens.
C’est ce dernier point
qui anime ma curiosité
et que je partage
avec plus de 100 000 personnes
sur le compte Instagram que j’ai créé :
« Merci Beaucul ».
Ce compte, je l’ai créé pour engager
et s’approprier la discussion
autour des sexualités
avec le plaisir au cœur de ces échanges.
Je m’appelle Léa et je suis persuadée
que le sexe, c’est bien plus que du sexe.
J’en ai fait l’expérience,
j’en fais encore l’expérience
et les personnes qui participent à mes
ateliers continuent de me le confirmer.
S’il y a bien une chose que toutes ces
personnes, moi la première, ont entendue,
c’est que la sexualité, c’est tabou,
personnel et surtout très, très privé.
Donc, j’ai décidé de parler de la mienne
à 1 100 personnes aujourd’hui.
(Rires)
Installez-vous bien,
je vais raconter une histoire.
(Applaudissements)
Il était une fois
la disparition de mes orgasmes.
Après plusieurs années
de plaisir en solitaire,
leur intensité a commencé à décliner.
On se rapprochait plutôt d’un éternuement,
un bon éternuement !
À côté de ça, lorsque j’étais
avec un partenaire : absentéisme complet.
J’ai un peu commencé
à me poser des questions.
J’avais fini par assimiler,
certainement comme beaucoup,
que j’étais une de ces personnes
qui n’auraient jamais d’orgasme.
Mon historique de recherche
ressemblait un peu à ça.
(Rires)
(Rit)
Je vaquais donc à mes péripéties
avec Pierre, Paul ou Jacques,
mais épaulée du vaillant Google,
j’ai fini par comprendre :
l’absence d’orgasme n’était
que la partie visible de l’iceberg.
Et alors, un monde entier s’est dévoilé.
Ma sexualité peut être vue comme
le reflet de ce qui se passe en moi.
On peut aller plus loin :
repérer le rapport que j’avais
à mon plaisir sexuel
m’a permis de me comprendre
à une échelle plus globale.
Par exemple, j’étais tellement concentrée
sur le plaisir de mon partenaire
que j’en oubliais complètement le mien.
Je passais des heures à chercher comment
faire la meilleure fellation de leur vie,
mais à côté de ça, demander
les choses qui me plaisaient vraiment ?
Impossible.
Ou alors j'avais honte que mon plaisir
mette autant de temps.
Donc, je préférais zapper complètement
certaines pratiques.
Après un rapport, j’avais un sentiment
de frustration, mais j’acceptais,
c’était comme ça.
En bref, mon plaisir sexuel passait
complètement au second plan.
Et quand j’ai réalisé ça,
j’ai réalisé que ce n’était pas seulement
au niveau de ma sexualité.
Je faisais des choses
pour faire plaisir à des amis,
même si ça me mettait mal à l'aise.
Ou j’avais beaucoup de mal
à passer du temps seule,
voire ça m’était carrément inconfortable.
Je faisais partie de la team pessimiste,
râler était ma grande passion,
je surconsommais.
En bref, j’avais du mal à reconnaître
et accueillir le plaisir dans ma vie.
Un peu comme si je ne le méritais pas.
À travers ma sexualité, j’ai aussi pu
comprendre mon rapport à mon corps,
mes envies, ma confiance en moi,
en bref, à l’estime que j’avais pour moi -
il n’y en avait pas beaucoup.
Aujourd’hui, des milliers de personnes
sont au courant de l’historique
de mes orgasmes.
En fait, à ce moment-là,
ma sexualité fut à l’origine
d’un épanouissement plus général.
Comprendre et prendre comme point
de départ mon désir et mon plaisir,
ça a été pour moi plus simple et tangible
qu'une introspection.
OK, mais alors concrètement,
qu’est-ce que ça a changé ?
Faisons un petit état
des lieux pré-exploration.
Pour commencer,
autant dire que je ne prenais
aucun plaisir ni à me regarder,
ni à être dans mon corps.
En fait, soit j’évitais de passer
devant un miroir pendant des semaines,
soit je passais 3 heures devant à scruter
chaque petit détail qui ne m’allait pas.
Équilibre...
Ensuite, ma confiance en moi.
À mon avis, elle n’avait pas dû
être livrée à la naissance.
Je me suis rendu compte
qu’elle se basait
sur l’accumulation de choses,
un peu comme si j’avais quelque chose
à prouver à quelqu’un.
Ce petit shoot de dopamine après un achat,
ça semblait être
ma seule source de réconfort.
Du coup, c’est vrai que mon plaisir
me paraissait très éphémère.
Mon slogan était :
« Ça ira mieux quand j’aurai ça »,
ou sa variante : « Quand je ferai ça,
je serai vraiment heureuse ».
Pouvoir apprécier ma situation actuelle
avec du recul,
ce n’était pas vraiment
quelque chose d’accessible.
Ok.
Comment j’ai fait pour en arriver là ?
Et qu’est-ce qui a changé ?
Aujourd'hui, mon corps, je le remercie.
Je le remercie d’être une source
de sensations incroyables
et presque infinies.
Je passe de bons petits moments avec,
je le mate, je le masse et je le mets
en valeur quand j’en ai envie.
Et quand des complexes surgissent,
je me souviens que, grâce à lui,
je peux vivre des connexions intenses
avec moi-même ou avec une autre personne.
Pour ça, je ne peux qu’avoir
de la bienveillance envers lui
et lui être reconnaissante.
J’ai aussi appris à m’ancrer
dans le moment présent, le fameux.
En me concentrant
par exemple sur le toucher,
le goût ou l’odorat
consciemment pendant un rapport,
j’ai pu facilement transférer ça
à mon quotidien.
Via ma sexualité,
j’ai développé une curiosité
pour la beauté de ce qui nous entoure.
L’odeur d’un bon plat, la douceur
d’un plaid, le clapotis de l’océan,
sont des sources de plaisir à ma portée.
C’est aussi via ma sexualité que j’ai
appris à me détacher de la performance
et à moins être toujours
dans l’attente de résultats,
jouir, faire jouir, comment, à quelle
vitesse, dans quelle position, combien ?
(Souffle)
En fait, apprendre à me détacher
de tout ça au profit des sensations,
ça m’a permis d’apprendre à apprécier
les expériences et
les petits plaisirs du quotidien.
Enfin, connaître l'orgasme à deux, ça a
boosté ma confiance en moi au quotidien.
Ben ouais, si quelque chose d’aussi
simple que me connaître et m’exprimer
égale plus de plaisir égale des orgasmes,
j’ai enfin pu me faire confiance
sur d’autres sujets.
Que ce soit
professionnellement ou personnellement,
je sais ce qui fonctionne
pour moi et je peux l’exprimer.
En apprenant à dire à Jacques
où était mon clito,
j’ai appris à dire non à des amis
ou à renvoyer un plat au resto.
Merci Jacques !
(Rires)
Une autre chose est arrivée pendant
cette aventure, chose un peu inattendue :
mon rapport aux gens s’est adouci -
mais vraiment.
Est-ce que toi aussi tu as déjà remis
en question le compliment de quelqu’un ?
« Qu’est-ce qu’il veut ? »
« Pourquoi il me dit ça ? »
« Je sais bien qu’elle exagère. »
Je vais m’adresser aux femmes :
toi aussi, t’es-tu déjà sentie
en compétition avec une autre femme
juste parce qu’elle était une femme ?
Hommes, femmes, partenaires sexuels
ou non, ils ne sont plus menaçants.
Ils ne sont plus les uniques
détenteurs de ma validation
ou réduits à des éléments de comparaison.
Ils et elles sont des possibilités.
Possibilités d’échange,
de partage, de découverte.
Possibilités d’apprentissage sur moi-même,
le monde, d’émotions et de sororité,
même éphémères.
Quand quelque chose a changé avec moi,
quelque chose a changé
avec le monde entier.
Quand j’ai commencé
à prendre du plaisir avec moi,
j’ai pu prendre du plaisir
avec les autres.
Aujourd’hui, je prête d’autres intentions
à ma sexualité.
Maintenant que j’y vois le potentiel d’une
expérience forte, seule ou à deux,
je ne peux que souhaiter ça
à tout le monde.
Je te souhaite cet accès au plaisir,
au bien-être
et à des orgasmes
qui dérangeront tes voisins.
(Rires)
Sorry !
à ma grande surprise, ouverture d’esprit,
créativité, empathie,
tout ça, ça peut se travailler
via sa sexualité.
La sexualité, c’est comme une loupe,
un microscope qui fait
le point sur qui on est,
qui on aimerait être
et qui on n’ose pas montrer.
C’est à mes yeux un moment d’exploration,
d’expression qui va au-delà des orgasmes.
C’est la métaphore de ton toi
primaire, mais aussi cérébral,
de ton imagination,
tes blessures, tes complexes,
ta joie, ta vulnérabilité.
Cette évolution n’est pas arrivée
du jour au lendemain.
Elle est passée
par plein d’étapes très différentes.
Par exemple, prononcer les mots
« vagin », « pénis », « orgasme »,
de la même manière que je demanderais
une baguette de pain,
ça a permis de les rendre non seulement
réels dans mon corps et non tabous.
Beaucoup plus simple
pour demander ce que je veux.
Cette évolution est aussi passée
par apprendre à respirer.
Oui, j'ai appris à respirer.
Ça, en fait, ça a permis non seulement de
comprendre le fonctionnement de mon corps,
mais aussi de rester présente
pendant un rapport.
Donc, la prochaine fois que tu penses
à ta liste de courses,
respire, ça va bien se passer.
Une des choses les plus compliquées,
ça a été d'apprendre à recevoir.
Ah oui, je sais, ce n’est pas facile.
On peut donner, donner,
mais recevoir un compliment, un cadeau
ou un cunni, c’est une autre histoire.
« Je vais prendre trop de temps », « je
ne suis pas épilée », « il va s’ennuyer ».
(Rires)
Non seulement j’ai appris à recevoir,
mais en plus, maintenant, j’apprécie
que mon partenaire ne soit concentré
que sur moi pendant un moment.
Cette évolution,
elle est passée par d’autres choses,
ça n’arrivait pas que
dans les moments sexuels.
C’est passé aussi par des moments
d’amour en solo, comme j’aime dire.
La masturbation, quoi.
Mais c’est aussi dans des moments du
quotidien que des changements s’opéraient.
La danse, l’art, la cuisine, la musique,
mais aussi en trouvant
des espaces de discussion en ligne
ou en ayant des réponses à mes questions.
En fait, tout ça, ça a contribué
à donner une légitimité à ma curiosité.
Et cette curiosité est une clé
qu’on peut tous et toutes développer.
Le lien entre quotidien et sexualité
m’est apparu beaucoup plus clairement :
ma sexualité n’est pas un aspect
compartimenté de ma personnalité,
mais une autre de ses manifestations.
Elle a été un véritable outil
d'évolution personnelle.
Cette sexualité, c’est une sexualité
investie et conscientisée.
En fait, l’idée, c’était de passer
du mode automatique -
je vois, j’entends, je mange -
au mode manuel -
je regarde, j’écoute, je déguste -
tout ça afin de créer des connexions
conscientes à mes sens et mes sensations.
Se connecter à ses sensations est
un truc qu’on peut faire tout le temps.
Même là, maintenant.
Mais tu sais quoi, je te propose même
qu'on découvre ça ensemble.
Essaye pendant
les quelques secondes qui suivent
de vraiment sentir le poids
de ton corps contre ta chaise.
Si tu as envie, tu peux fermer les yeux.
Ce n’est pas du tout obligatoire,
mais ça peut aider à se concentrer.
Essaye de ressentir la texture
de cette chaise,
celle de tes vêtements
contre ta peau.
Concentre-toi sur les sensations
dans le bas de ton dos,
dans tes épaules,
dans ta nuque.
Observe comment ta langue
est posée dans ta bouche,
l’air froid qui rentre dans tes narines
et l’air chaud qui en ressort.
Tu peux rouvrir les yeux.
Félicitations, tu viens de travailler
sur ta sexualité.
Et tu n’es pas solo.
J’ai fait un sondage sur Instagram,
plus de 7 000 personnes ont répondu.
94 % ont dit qu’en s’investissant
dans la sexualité,
ils et elles ont vu une évolution.
Mais plus de 6 000 ont aussi vu un impact
positif sur leur bien-être en général.
Tu vas me dire :
« Oui, mais la sexualité, c’est inné.
On n’a besoin de rien, on ne va
pas travailler dessus pour évoluer. »
Je dirais oui, mais manger, c’est inné,
et pourtant, on fait des recettes d’une
complexité loin d’être indispensable,
mais qui colorent nos quotidiens.
Parfois, tu commandes un Deliveroo,
parfois, tu te fais à manger
pendant trois heures.
Les deux vont t’apporter du plaisir
mais ne pas avoir les mêmes bénéfices.
Là, c’est un peu la même chose.
Comprendre que je pouvais
« me préparer un repas »
pour explorer autre chose
que la réponse à une pulsion de désir,
ça a ouvert la porte à plein
de possibilités.
Bien sûr, je vais manger encore
du surgelé, de la junk food,
mais le truc, c’est que personne
ne m’a dit que je pouvais faire ça.
On ne m'a pas prévenu que mon plaisir
sexuel était aussi important et valable
qu'un autre.
Quand on sait qu’aujourd’hui,
une lycéenne sur quatre ne sait pas
que le clitoris est l’homologue
du pénis et l’organe du plaisir.
À mon avis, ce n’est pas mieux
chez les lycéens que leurs darons.
(Rires)
Quand, en 2021, on parle encore
d’orgasme clitoridien ou vaginal -
et - spoiler alert -
les deux viennent du clitoris
et que selon une étude de l’IFOP de 2019,
52 % des femmes interrogées ont
encore des difficultés à l’atteindre.
La moitié !
Qu’on pense encore qu’une
éjaculation est forcément un orgasme,
je me dis qu’il nous reste
des choses à apprendre.
J’aspire à déclencher
cette envie d’apprendre,
à stimuler la curiosité,
la soif de se découvrir,
soi et l’autre,
qu’ensemble, on remette en question
les normes qui nous ont été imposées
et qu’on se réapproprie notre plaisir.
J’aimerais affirmer que
se pencher sur ta sexualité,
ça te mènera forcément
vers un happy end à base de
« elle vécut heureuse
et eut plein d’orgasmes »,
mais ce serait te vendre du rêve.
La sexualité, c’est comme tout,
ça vient par cycles,
avec des hauts et des bas.
Parfois, j’ai envie et parfois,
je n’ai pas envie, c’est ok.
Si j’osais, je mettrais
une phrase d’inspiration :
« Ce n’est pas la destination qui compte,
mais le voyage. »
(Rires)
Et aujourd’hui en sera peut-être
le point de départ.
On ne va pas se le cacher,
mais tout ce que je dis là
peut paraître osé et courageux,
mais c’est plus facile à dire
et à vivre quand on est
une femme, blanche, cisgenre,
hétéro, mince.
Même avec tous ces privilèges,
finalement, n’est pas une recherche
qui a été innée ou facile à entamer.
C’est en me penchant sur ma sexualité
que j’ai vu que celle des autres
était loin d’être acceptée,
voire carrément ouvertement
discriminée au calme.
Certaines personnes subissent
des actes violents
pour une chose aussi innée, naturelle,
que leur orientation,
leur genre, leur identité.
Parce que parler de sexualité,
c’est parler du profondément humain
et ne pas évoquer ces réalités,
ce serait nier des expériences humaines,
parce que non,
tout le monde n’a pas la sécurité,
l’environnement adapté pour explorer
et exprimer sa sexualité.
Célébrer l’expression de la nôtre, c’est
à mes yeux d’une importance capitale.
Partir de nos corps
qui disposent naturellement d’outils
qu’on a tendance à prendre pour acquis -
nos sens, notre respiration, nos muscles -
ça peut être un moyen simple
de se connecter à soi
et de prendre du plaisir sexuellement
et au quotidien.
L’expression « Connais-toi toi-même »
prend alors un tout autre sens.
La sexualité peut être la genèse,
l’épiphanie qui met en branle tout le
mécanisme de l’épanouissement de soi,
pour soi, et avec quelqu’un d’autre
si on en a envie.
La bonne nouvelle, c’est que
cet enrichissement est à portée de main
ou de doigt.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)